[Musique]
mais dans le débat sur france 24 un
procès historique celui de l'assassinât
de thomas sankara des condamnations
lourdes la prison à perpétuité pour
l'ancien président du burkina faso
blaise compaore mais aussi pour le
commandant de sa garde hyacinthe kafando
prison à perpétuité aussi pour le
général gilbert dienderé un des chefs de
l'armée tous les trois sont condamnés
pour attentat à la sûreté de l'état de
compaore et dienderé sont également
reconnus coupables de complicité
d'assassinât assassinat donc de thomas
sankara tuer avec 12 de ses compagnons
lors d'un coup d'état c'était il ya 34
ans alors quelles sont les réactions
après ce verdict les peines prononcées
sont l exemplaire pourquoi ce procès
sankara est-il historique l'assassinât
de thomas sankara est il maintenant une
affaire classée on va en parler avec mes
invités j'ai plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
pierre olivier sur bonsoir avocats de
blaise compaore bienvenue dans le débat
nous avons également à ouagadougou en
direct m guy hervé kam avocats des
familles des victimes bonsoir à vous et
bienvenue également
également
bonsoir également parce qu'avec de l'eau
mais cette fois louis magoar claude
mailloux journaliste et président du
club de l'information africaine bonsoir
louis magloire
bonsoir on attend également à
ouagadougou dieudonné azulgrana qui est
avec nous ou pas toujours pas mieux on
l'attend directeur de la publication au
quotidien aujourd'hui au faso les
condamnations à perpétuité des trois
principaux protagonistes dont l'ancien
président burkinabè je le disais
plaisent compaore ont eu lieu à l'issue
d'un procès qui a duré six mois un
procès qui s'est ouvert donc 34 ans
après la mort de thomas sankara une
icône panafricaine assassiné lors d'un
coup d'état qui avait justement porté au
pouvoir blaise compaore ont fait un
point en images avec bilal tarabel
blaise compaore en exil en côte d'ivoire
gilbert dienderé présent à l'audience
un militaire en fuite hyacinthe kafando
tous condamnés à la prison à perpétuité
les juges du tribunal militaire de
ouagadougou sont allés encore plus loin
que les réquisitions du parquet
militaire concernant les trois
principaux accusés dans le procès pour
l'assassinât de thomas sankara
c'est un sentiment de fierté
d'appartenir au cross du lycée c'est un
sentiment de fierté
d'appartenir donc à ce pays le burkina
faso est d'avoir une justice au dessus
de la mêlée thomas sankara été tué par
un commando le 15 octobre 1987 avec 12
de ses collaborateurs plus de 34 ans
après son assassinat il reste une icône
panafricaine blaise compaore lui avait
succédé tout de suite après sa mort il
est resté 27 ans au pouvoir avant d'être
renversé par la rue en 2014 et de
s'exiler en côte d'ivoire ce procès a
établi que thomas sankara été tuées par
des membres de la garde de blaise
compaoré
les juges l'ont condamné à perpétuité
par contumace pour attentat à la sûreté
de l'état et complicité d'assassinât
les magistrats ont aussi établi que
l'opération avait été coordonnée par le
général gilbert dienderé un proche de
blaise compaore le seul des trois
principaux accusés présents au procès
puisqu'il purge déjà une peine de 20 ans
de prison pour un coup d'état en 2015
est ce que vous allez faire appel c'est
notre client qui va décider puisque nous
sommes arrêtés pennac vous à lui
conseillé de faire appel
bon tout est une question c'est ça le
concerne d'abord les autres accusés dans
ce procès ont été condamnés à des peines
allant de trois à vingt ans de prison
trois autres ont été acquittés tous les
condamnés peuvent faire appel
et on va tout de suite écoutez la
réaction de la femme la veuve de thomas
sankara mariam sankara
le juge a rendu son
verdict mais
nous avons eu beaucoup de nous avons
connu beaucoup de vérité beaucoup de
choses était dite là on a pu vérifier
certaines choses et tout
dieudonné zoungrana vous avez rejoint
directeur de publication du quotidien
aujourd'hui au faso pour justement
redonner un peu de contexte à ce procès
thomas sankara est une icône en afrique
le fait que ce procès est aboutie s
historique et quelles sont les réactions
à ses peines est ce qu'elles sont
exemplaires ses peines
oui je pense que c'est ces procès
historiques ce procès hors normes de pas
l'envergure même de thomas sankara qui
aujourd'hui est une figure iconique
cc je crois que l e min et l'allégeance
entremêle cdu concernant le fringant
capitaine qui a débaptisé haute volta
burkina faso
maintenant pour le venue au procès je
pense que c'est c'est les juges sont
allés au maximum de notre droit pénal
qui a supprimé la peine de mort ils sont
allés plus loin même que le réquisitoire
du procureur et de mariam sankara qui
pouvait justement cette histoire trop
clément donc je pense que bon
l'un dans l'autre le droit a été dit
mais n'a bon dans le déroulé de notre
émission verra si elle eu droit il avait
la vérité et la justice ont été dites
on attend maintenant de voir
là chacun est ce que sera la
réconciliation
le triptyque temps céline et réclame un
par les populations burkinabè m guy
hervé kam vous êtes l'avocat des
familles de victimes quelles ont été les
réactions des familles est-ce qu'elles
jugent ces peines exemplaires
oui écoutez je pense que pour les
familles le plus important ce n'était
pas vraiment le quantum de la peine le
plus important c'était la réponse à deux
questions fondamentales
est ce que les personnes poursuivies ont
commis les faits est ce qu'il existe des
circonstances atténuantes la réponse à
cette question était importante est
alors plus importante pour les familles
que le quantum de la peine qui dépend du
juge maintenant
ses résultats tôt si on peut le dire
ainsi les juges ont prononcé des peines
qui peut paraître lourde mais il ne faut
pas oublier que les accusés ne n'ont
jamais accepté de coopérer les acquis
des deux est au contraire se sont mis
dans une posture d défiance à l'égard de
la justice n'ont jamais reconnu même si
tous les faits les accable est quand
c'est comme ça très souvent les juges
devant dans le maximum lorsqu'il n'ya
aucune circonstance atténuante pour les
familles le plus important c'était
vraiment là je le répète encore le plus
important c'était que la vérité
judiciaire soit dit d'autant plus que la
vérité des faits notre vérité nous la
savions depuis 35 ans mais c'était pas
le plus important le plus important
c'était la vérité de la justice et
l'entendre aujourd'hui 35 ans après 25
ans de procédure après c'est un grand
soulagement pour les familles qui
peuvent maintenant et penser au passé
aux deux mètres pierre-olivier sûr vous
représentez vous blaise compaore votre
réaction à cette cette condamnation bien
il ya d'abord une réaction
procédurale vous savez que ce procès est
intervenue sans la présence de blaise
compaoré qui est en côte d'ivoire et en
côte d'ivoire donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle une procédure de contumace in
abstentia et le code de procédure alors
prévoit que si la personne est condamnée
elle est condamnée au maximum ce qui
fait que la perpétuité n'est pas une
surprise c'est j'allais dire un choix
face auquel le président blon blaise
compaoré s'est placé lui-même un
deuxième chose que je veux dire c'est
que quand le penser c'est ouvert sans
vouloir jouer les cassandre
j'avais parlé avant de savoir ce qu'il
allait se passer de chaos judiciaire
annoncée et c'est très exactement bas le
fil des audiences d'abord on le sait les
jurés
généraux et colonels qui est les uns
après les autres ont refusé de
participer au jury ce ont jeté l'épongé
en quelque sorte et puis ensuite on le
sait même je suis étonné que personne
n'ait parlé encore le coup d'état qui a
suspendu l'état de droit au burkina faso
et on a fait un pont au-dessus de ce
coup d'état pour terminer avec ce
verdict dans une salle où j'ai
l'impression qu'ils avaient assez peu de
monde d'ailleurs comme si finalement au
burkina faso on s'intéresse à d'autres
choses qui apparaissent plus importantes
comme on dit chez nous le pouvoir
d'achat et puis le terrorisme vous allez
faire appel excédé pour ya deux
solutions évidemment soit nous laissons
ce verdict eh bien nous l'abandonnons
j'allais presque dire la poubelle de
l'histoire judiciaire parce que
franchement
c'est pas un verdict digne d'une justice
digne d'un état de droit vous le savez
nous n'avons participé à aucun acte
d'instruction pourquoi parce que nous
n'avons jamais été convoqué on ne nous a
jamais notifié aucune décision et
lorsque le procès a été suspendu une
première fois et puis renvoyés et bien
parce que j'avais dit qu'on nous avait
jamais rien notifié
les services du greffe sont allés
placardée sur la porte de la maison de
blaise campaoré une convocation
judiciaire c'est la première convocation
qu'on ait jamais reçue qui était
placardé au milieu du procès alors donc
non ce procès n'a pas respecté les
règles de l'état de droit du procès ce
n'est pas la vérité dont on vient de
parler m guy hervé kam b et non de
vérité non c'est un simulacre de
procédure alors dont je réponds tout de
même à votre question 1 on a le choix
entre laisser dans les poubelles de
l'histoire judiciaire cette mauvaise
décision du studio ces rappels ou bien
de saisir effectivement les juridictions
supérieures au burkina mais surtout les
juridictions internationales et là je
prends le pari j'en suis certain cette
procédure ce verdict ne peut pas passer
et bien par le prisme et par le filtre
de la justice pénale internationale
on va en parler justement l'une magloire
que mayuka sont les réactions dans le
reste de l'afrique après l'annnonce de
ses peines notamment en afrique de
l'ouest est ce que on a là seul le
sentiment d'un d'une fin de l'impunité
comme on a pu l'entendre par exemple
dans la bouche d'un proche d'une victime
on ne peut pas utiliser ce qui vient de
se passer parce que et a jamais eu de
procès paramore rapports
et de nombreuses autres
ont été tuées
et dont on n'a jamais su très
précisément ce qui s'était passé et dont
les auteurs de l'assassinât n'ont jamais
été identifiés
donc je ne me permettrais pas de traité
ce procès de simulacre parce qu'il ya
deux bonnes raisons pour lesquelles on
ne peut pas passer crette ce procès de
cette façon la première c'est que on a
quand même besoin dans un dans une
affaire comme celle-là que la justice
passe elle peut être bonne ou mauvaise
pour qu'elle passe la deuxième c'est que
la cédéao l'espace auquel appartient le
burkina faso à une cour de justice et
même si la cedeao n'est pas très
crédible auprès des populations sa cour
de justice a beaucoup de a beaucoup
d'admiration de la part des populations
qu'ils la saisissent très régulièrement
et qui obtiennent gain de cause donc si
les populations qui sont généralement
dépourvus de et face au gouvernement
arrive à obtenir gain de cause auprès de
la cour de justice de la cedeao je ne
vois pas comment le président compaoré
ou les autres accusés ne pourraient pas
obtenir gain de cause et je termine là
dessus en disant pour une fois la paix
prend ses responsabilités et c'est tant
mieux c'est peut-être un parfait mais
c'est déjà ça je pense que c'est devenu
quelque peu sus des masculins pour les
justice africaine et pour les
populations africaines de se retrouver
avec leurs citoyens et leur vie ils sont
perpétuellement jugé hors de leur
continent est loin des lieux où les
faits ont été commis non pour toutes ces
raisons là j'estime que c'est un premier
bon maître guy hervé kam que répondez
vous justement à mettre pierre-olivier
sûr quand il dit que c'est un simulacre
le procès a duré six mois pour redonner
un peu de contexte il s'est beaucoup
fondée sur des témoignages c'est ça
plutôt
écoutez moi j'aurais souhaité d'ailleurs
ne pas répondre à cela parce que je
comprends parfaitement en général quand
un avocat c'est que son client n'a
aucune chance dans un procès il se met
donc dans une posture qui a une posture
donc de critiques de défiance sinon vous
verrez bien la contradiction alors que
on reconnaît parfaitement que la
perpétuité est une peine normale quand
un accusé ne comparaît pas le seul
reproche donc préféré c'est de dire on
n'a pas reçu de convocation et bien moi
je suis avocat 1er mai m olivier sur et
je sais pertinemment que au pire des cas
même si vous n'avez pas reçu de réponse
de convocation vous pouvez prendre part
être volontairement dans une audience
blaise compaoré en tant que chef d'état
aurait eu je ne parlerai même pas
d'élégance mais tout simplement la
dignité de comparaître personnellement
et de répondre qu'on aurait compris et
la fuit la justice
on peut on peut inventer tout autre
chose pour couvrir ceux là mais le fait
est que dans cette affaire il y avait
douze accusés qui étaient présents qui
avait plusieurs à des avocats venant de
bach aux différents et personne n'a émis
cette critique contre la procédure qui
de toute évidence a été une procédure
équitable car m pierre-olivier sûr donc
c'est vrai qu'il aurait pu se déplacer
il aurait pu dire oui mais est-ce
compaore pour pouvoir aller a fait venir
pourquoi les t-il venir devant une
justice qu'ils avaient ignoré pendant la
phase d'instruction du procès vous savez
que dans tout procès pénal est d'abord
une phase d' enquête puis une phase
d'instruction une phase de jugement eh
bien ni dans la phase d' enquête ni dans
la phase d'instruction c'est à dire
avant les six mois de procès il a été
convoqué et il était invité à venir pour
être entendus pour être confrontée pour
qu'on lui notifie les expertises pour
qu'on lui offre la possibilité de faire
des demandes d'actes c'est à dire voilà
il y aurait bien sûr fut pas et c'est à
dire action quand c'est à dire qu'on l'a
ignoré pendant le temps de l'enquêté et
de l'instruction et qu'alors il n'était
pas question qu'il arrive comme un
gibier de potence dans le cadre de cette
salle d'audience où je le redis encore
il y avait assez peu de monde
aujourd'hui pour être purement et
simplement condamné tandis qu'il y à
d'autres sujets de préoccupation et
permettez moi de vous le dire et je
salue avec confiance la nouvelle équipe
au gouvernement parce que elle a indiqué
qu'elle s'engageait vers une
réconciliation nationale et cette
réconciliation nationale me paraît la
chose la plus importante pour le burkina
et pour son histoire en tout cas ce
procès n'aurait pas été possible pendant
le mandat devait se compaore
pierre-olivier sur il était président de
la république bien sûr que c'était pas
possible pendant le mandat de blaise
compaore vous bon il fait et d'ailleurs
est ce possible encore aujourd'hui
tandis qu'il bénéficie vous le savez
d'une immunité qui avait été votée elle
même par le président roch kaboré qu'est
ce qui vous a dit aujourd'hui quand vous
lui avez quand il a su qu'elle est ne
dévoile jamais les conversations je peux
avoir avec mes clients en revanche s'y
attendait dit en revanche je vous dis
oui passerait bien sûr c'était m'éclater
on n'a même pas attendu le verdict avec
un bad panther en se disant oh la la
qu'est ce qui va se passer le seul sujet
pour nous c est ce qu on s'inscrit dans
un processus de réconciliation nationale
en y répondant favorablement
où est-ce qu'on s'inscrit dans un
processus de pourvoi et de saisine de la
cour de justice à cedeao ou africaine je
ne sais pas encore je dois dire que je
pense qu'il serait meilleur pour tout le
monde que nous puissions nous retrouver
autour de la table de la réconciliation
nationale
louis my work mailloux est votre
réaction à ce que vient de dire m
pierre-olivier sûr il peut y avoir une
réconciliation déjà aujourd'hui ça veut
dire quoi un retour de blaise compaore
ça passerait par quoi cette
réconciliation
non je crois que la réconciliation et
les incontournables c'est la troisième
caisse de l'édifice qui doit être bâti
aujourd'hui parce que après le procès
après les sanctions il faut bien
continuer de vivre et on ne peut pas
vivre sans réconciliation donc j'espère
que chacun donnera du sien au niveau des
condamnés au niveau de la population
pour que cette réconciliation passe et
que tous les enfants du faso se
remettent dans l'ordre de marge qui leur
permettra de rester digne de ce qu'a été
la révolution initiée par thomas sankara
parce qu'au bout du compte ce qui coince
et cela en moins de quatre ans il est
l'ami le burkina faso en orbite sur non
seulement la place africaine mais
également à l'échelle internationale les
thématiques abordées
qu'il s'agisse des droits des femmes
qu'il s'agisse de l'écologie qu'il
s'agisse de la dette qu'il s'agisse de
tous les sujets la lutte contre
l'impérialisme encore une fois ce sont
tous ces sujets là qui reviennent
aujourd'hui le court beaucoup utilisent
dans leurs discours sans prendre parfois
la fen qu'incarnait 1940 de matraques
oui attendez juste dieudonné zoungrana
ce que vous souhaiteriez vous êtes
d'accord avec lui d'accord mais je
voudrais mettre pierre olivier sur juste
je voudrais faire intervenir
donnez une grenade faudrait peut-être
rappeler un peu aussi le contexte
dieudonné la prise du pouvoir donc du
temps colonel damiba après ce coup de
force on l'a pas beaucoup entendu alors
m pierre-olivier sûr il faisait allusion
il ya il y à une minute il ya eu le
procès a été repoussé une ou deux fois
est ce que aujourd'hui finalement il a
réagi ou pas
au nom officiellement je n'avais pas eu
connaissance mais il faut il faut quand
même contextualiser et qui ment comme
vous l'avez dit vous savez que le
dossier est thomas sankara a connu a été
dépoussiéré sous un régime de transition
en 2015 parce que c'est la transition en
2015 et a dépoussiéré et qui a donné un
coup d'accélérateur à ce dossier
emblématique là et ironie du sort c'est
sous une transition que ce verdict que
ce projet a connu son épilogue avec le
verdict mais mais mais je voudrais peut
répondre rapidement mettre
pierre-olivier sûr que je connais un peu
je respecte bon c'est vrai qu'il est un
peu dans la posture de cicéron qui
disait que la plus grande justice est la
plus grande injustice mais est-ce qu'il
faut se poser la question est ce que ce
procès était équitable est ce que les
projets ont eu droit à un procès
équitable oui ou non oui nous à ce qu il
faut ce qu'il faut ce dire quand même
que est aujourd'hui là je suis burkinabè
ça vous pouvez inquiétez vous êtes venus
ici caillavet est le pot c'est là la
sphère et france à comparer je vous ai
voulu à l'époque est ce qu'aujourd'hui
ce procès si vous écoutez les minutes du
procès est ce qu'il ya eu des entorses
est ce qu'il ya eu vraiment et dire que
faure
c'est une vraiment c'est ce procès est
ce que la justice ait et vous n'avez
indépendante oui ou non oui je passe
vous n'est ce pas blessé et cela dit et
soit dit en passant pour parler de
réconciliation
qu'il fait un peu comme quand je dis le
lieu le 3e maillot de ce puzzle la roma
t il et il est aujourd'hui question
d'amnistié
parce qu'il ya la mystique qui est déjà
dans les tuyaux avec et et la nouvelle
assemblée nationale et l'assemblée
législative mais qui pose problème à la
longue est-ce qu'il faut opter pour
l'industrie ou bien pour la grâce
présidentielle
je crois que la balle est dans le camp
bon en tout cas des pouvoirs actuels
mais il faut quand même saluer cette
indépendance de la justice dix fois ça
dure aussi la persévérance du commerce m
pierre olivier si on vous répond alors
donc alors chers amis moi aussi je vous
respecte et je vous salue et on a
effectivement un certain nombre de
souvenirs en commun
j'ai aimé aller au burkina et plaider au
burkina devant une justice qui fait ce
qu'elle peut dans un pays que je
respecte infiniment de même que vous
tous et tous mes confrères qui sont là
ce que je veux dire c'est que je n'étais
pas dans le cadre de cette salle
d'audience en revanche je n'étais pas
non plus à l'instruction et je sais que
l'instruction s'est passée sans blaise
campaoré du fait de la justice burkinabè
qui n'a pas daigné le convoquer lui
notifier quoi vous revenir je reviens
mais c'est très important alors
maintenant je voudrais qu'on arrête sur
les polémiques sur le process que
c'était un bon pro c'est un mauvais
procès voudrait c'est ce qu'il faut
c'est oui mais je l'assumé je suis en
mesure de passer au delà et de vous dire
maintenant qu'est ce qu'il faut vous
avez dit du bien du souvenir du de
sankara et je le reconnais c'est
évidemment un personnage iconique de
votre beau pays et du très grand
continent africain il en restera l'un
des phares mais je viens vous dire aussi
que le président blaise compaore pour sa
part continue à être très populaire au
burkina et son souvenir n'a pas
complètement disparu lui aussi a
participé à cette oeuvre qui fait que
votre pays existent sur la scène
internationale sont la revue a signé là
sous la pression de la rue bien sûr mais
il a fait partie aussi de ceux qui ont
écrit l'histoire du pays est ce qu'ils
ont écrit
voir du pays qui suivent les autres qui
l'ont écrite aussi tandis que chacun a
commis sans doute des fautes et des
erreurs et bien participent à cette idée
de nation et de continuité d'une
histoire et le burkina mérite
aujourd'hui une réconciliation de blaye
nasa veut dire ça veut dire un retour au
pays de retour bien sûr il faut qu'ils
reviennent au pays et je crois que
beaucoup au pays l'attendent et lui
feront sinon un triomphe mais
l'accueillerons avec comme on dirait la
tendresse d'enfants pour l'un de leur
paie alors maître guy hervé kam vous
pouvez répondre à m pierre-olivier sûr
il serait accueilli les bras ouverts
alors il faut rappeler effectivement
qu'il est partie poussé on peut dire
après des manifestations importantes
mais entre temps il ya eu un coup de
force dont je le disais au mois de
janvier dernier vous qu'attendez vous en
faites de la suite maintenant après ses
condamnations est ce que il devrait être
extradé de côte d'ivoire mais ce qu'a en
rire qu'il devrait être amnistié est-ce
qu'ils devraient voilà
avant de répondre à ces questions je
voulais quand même d'élever deux contres
vérités qui ont été donc dit ici
concernant notamment l'immunité il a été
dit donc que l'immunité a et la loi
d'immunité a été prise donc disons
d'amnesty a été a été prise sous le
président alors kaboré ce n'est pas
exact c'est blaise compaoré qui sentant
la fin prochaine quand il y avait des
contestations sur la révision de
l'article 37 qui a pris cette loi pour
s'auto amnistier disons le et la
deuxième conservation sur ça c'est que
l'amnistié a été prise pour les chefs
des l'états et le 15 octobre 4e 27 quand
blaise compaore tu sankara et sec est un
malade pour prendre le pouvoir il
n'était pas chef d'état donc ces actes
ne peut pas être couverts par la loi
d'amnesty on ne pourra revenir à la
question qui a un lien avec
la réconciliation je dois dire que
personnellement j'aurais été très
heureux que blaise compaore rendre de
lui même au burkina faso mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il s'auto exclu lui-même
de la réconciliation pourquoi j'ai dit
ça parce que il n'ya pas et on la dit
très souvent dans ce pays la
réconciliation
amnésie ne fait pas avancer les pays moi
je comprends pierre paul-hus dessus il
n'est pas burkinabè il ne vit pas au
burkina c'est qui va advenir du burkina
aujourd'hui aider mais ne l'intéressent
par nous que cette question intéresse
nous pensons qu'on ne peut pas et passez
donc à la réconciliation sans la vérité
sans les excuses blaise compaore a
refusé de comparaître devant la justice
et la défier la russie qui continue de
dire que c'est un simulacre de procès
par l'intermédiaire de son conseil je ne
sais pas sur quel pied avec qui et dans
quel contexte ils voudraient annonce sur
le concilier quand je suis devant maître
guy hervé kam demandé l'été il a été
condamné à la perpétuité donc s'il
rentrait au burkina faso a priori il
sera en voyant en prison sa condamnation
c'est la perpétuité oui mais souvent we
thought and his team et ben là c'est la
prison elle est faite la prison elle est
la prison elle est faite pour les hommes
blaise compaore a embastillé plusieurs
personnes je précise que sankara et les
douze personnes n'ont pas eu droit à la
prison ils sont allés directement de
l'autre côté à partir de ce moment que
blaise compaore vienne et à la prison
c'est pas une question fondamentale pour
nous la question fondamentale pour nous
ce que blaise compaore s'adresse au
peuple burkinabè et reconnaissent
éventuellement sa part de responsabilité
pour que ce peuple a puisse penser à lui
pardonner dans le canton fui la justice
quand on conteste sa responsabilité
comment peut-on bene passer directement
à la réconciliation sans la vérité nous
avons eu aujourd'hui la vérité
judiciaire mais vous êtes là vous êtes
témoin de ce que blaise compaore dans
les échanges avec son avocat considère
que c'est un simulacre de procès
considère qu'il serait devenu un gibier
donc il ne reconnaît même pas la justice
de son pays qu'il a mis en place et
comment passez donc à une telle
réconciliation si ce n'est pas une
réconciliation amnésique mais vos
confrères mon confrère guy hervé kam que
là encore je respecte car je respecte
toujours ceux qui sont mes
contradicteurs eh bien il était un très
bon avocat mais c'est surtout un homme
politique qui est descendue dans la rue
pour faire partie de ceux qui ont voulu
chasser blaise campaoré par la force et
qui à l'époque ne faisait pas confiance
aux droits moi je fais confiance au
burkina faso je fais confiance en son
peuple dont j'ai quelques raisons de
croire qu'ils attendent le retour de
l'ancien président parmi eux pour passer
à autre chose et pour participer à cette
réconciliation nationale a compris à m
car
oui à les y attendait
d'eux oui alors à pigeon rapidement non
non non juste une précision sur ce point
voilà sur la le respect du droit moi je
voulais dire à m olivier sûr que sous
blaise compaoré au burkina faso un
ministre emblématique de la justice a
dit qu'il avait des juges acquis et que
c'était normal et le droit et la justice
à laquelle moi je fais confiance c'est
celle dans laquelle il n'y a pas de juge
à qui met des juges indépendants et
c'est ce que nous avons dans le burkina
peut se comparer moi je me suis battu
dans le bouquet nasu compaoré pour avoir
cette justice là
où
certains pièges les magistrats
militaires de haut rang qui ont refusé
de participer au jury qui allait juger
blaise campaoré était indépendant et que
ce n'est pas la raison pour laquelle ils
ont jeté l éponge louis magloire
keumayou et j'aimerais que vous
réagissiez on vous est ce que c'est ce
que tous les coudes c'est ce que tous
les côtes du monde prévoir lorsque un
juge sans fin qu'il ne peut pas il n'est
pas sûr qu'il va être impartial il s'est
désisté c'est ce que c'est aux
militaires en fait et j'étais fier que
des militaires généraux des colonels
viennent à l'audience d'hier je ne suis
pas sûr d'être impartial dont je refuse
d'être juge on ne peut pas demander
mieux c'est le symbole n'est ce pas du
burkinabé le pays des hommes intègres
très bien vieillot native du quinté
l'eponge beaumier skim avoir une règle
la question s'est posée de façon
récurrente louis mayer keumayou est-ce
que c'est finalement le procès d'un
système et pas seulement de blaise
compaore
je crois qu'on va au delà de leur procès
du système et je crois que le fait de se
renvoyer la balle ne peut que manger à
quel point il ya beaucoup de passion qui
est dégagé plein dedans et je pense
qu'il faut rappeler sur le plan
historique dans quel contexte baisse
le président sankara meurt c'est mon
année à l'autre de la chute du mur de
berlin on est à loupe également de tous
ces mouvements de l'évolution qui ont
permis que de l'expression démocratique
puisse se faire à travers les urnes à
travers les journaux à travers une
société civile qui avait du mal à
exister dans la plupart des décès et
pays africains et dont il symbolise tous
ces précurseurs qui se sont battus et
qui n'ont malheureusement pas pu là qui
n'ont pas vu la montagne ils n'y sont
pas arrivés et ça donne une dimension
presque si on est chrétien à la fois mon
dos moïse ou de christ par rapport à
thomas sankara
parce que l'on aurait aimé qu'il fut
l'un pour assister à ce printemps de la
démocratie que ce soit au moins des
années 90 ou un peu plus tard en cela
est arrivé parce que beaucoup de chefs
d'états rapport sur le continent guerre
aujourd'hui sans doute boeren raid au
pouvoir avant en cavale easy son accord
et le type
leur pays comme l'a fait thomas sankara
et je voulais juste te répondre à mettre
sur en disant que ayant présidents
d'afrique centrale qui était le
président centrafricain bokassa que
beaucoup de monde renault en france qui
a qui rentrait et qui a utilisé de tous
les subterfuges pour entrer dans son
pays afin d'être jugé pourtant on ne lui
permettait pas de rentrer pour avoir
droit à ce procès là donc je pense que
sa grande toujours la personne qui peut
respecter les astuces deux sont bien
respectés les populations de son pays en
venant donner sa part de vérité sa part
d'histoire dans le cours de cette de
ceux qu'il a écrits ou de ce qu'il en
est en vérité avec des rotations alors
d'anciens collaborateurs de sankara vous
réagirez juste après mais évoque des
relations tendues entre blaise compaore
thomas sankara l'existence d'un complot
international ourdi contre le leader
progressiste qui voulaient bouleversé
l'ordre du monde on disait à l'époque
éradiquer la pauvreté dans son pays on
va écouter thomas sankara ce qu'il avait
pu dire justement lors de la visite de
françois mitterrand le 17 novembre
c'est dans ce contexte monsieur françois
mitterrand que nous n'avons pas compris
comment des bandits comme jonas savimbi
des tueurs comme pieter botha en eu le
droit de parcourir la france si belle et
si pop ils l'ont attaché et dieudonné
zoungrana quelle est la thèse du complot
international contre thomas sankara ça
tient la route est-ce qu'ils auraient
une implication de la france dans
l'assassinât est ce que la côte d'ivoire
aussi par exemple de l'époque seraient
impliqués
oui nous avons tous entendu ça et bon ça
on nous avait fait écouter
le verbatim le sankara mais elle le
celui que les français appellent dieu
françois mitterrand a répondu il a mis
de côté son discours qu'il avait
proposées et la lèpre moss et il a
répondu à 100 cadavres savez c'était
quand même 2 2 2 fois tête deux grands 0
alors mitterrand avait dit à l'époque à
sankara à vous êtes tranchant mais vous
tranchez trop
voilà ce que mitterrand avait est ce que
la france est complice du régicide dr 87
je pense que la réponse était de la
phrase ne transparaît pas tarder en
groupe les minutes du procès si les
envoyés spéciaux des missi dominici
au lieu en ag dans l'ombre pour cela
n'engage pas l'état français a en tout
cas c'est ce qui transparaît et les noms
et les rapports diplomatiques aussi le
monde nul pas que la responsabilité de
la france en tant qu'etat est engagé
idem pour la côte d'ivoire nous avons
tous entendu ça mais il n'a pas été
clairement prouvé que un pic à la
responsabilité étatique de la france en
tous cas engagées dans l'assassinât de
thomas sankara bon je termine en disant
quand même tout ce procès parce que moi
je voulais je voulais quand même revenir
sur ça c'est un peu un peu plus en avant
et c'est à dire que ce procès quand même
à prouver que le crime politique ne paye
plus en afrique quel que soit votre
inverse une voix puissante du moment bon
il faut il faut faire gaffe et tous les
dirigeants africains doivent vider leurs
contentieux et pour unique lunel avant
deux parties sinon vous serez toujours
attraper un jour tôt ou tard voilà ce
que je voulais dit m pierre-olivier sur
sur cette thèse du complot international
au total a imagé et est extraordinaire
on à thomas sankara qui donne une leçon
de droit de l'homme à françois
mitterrand en lui disant nous sommes
tous de l'internationale socialiste mais
vous depuis que vous êtes président de
la république vous en avez trahi les
valeurs et il faut voir la suite de la
séquence avec mitterrand qui met une
main un peu paternaliste sur les poules
de thomas sankara et qui lui dit vous
exagérez vous êtes tranchant et caetera
et puis il part furieux furieux et il
s'est passé quelque chose il s'est passé
quelque chose mais quoi et la vérité
dans cette affaire peut-être qu'on va la
voir bientôt puisque le président
emmanuel macron à juste titre a promis
de déclassifier secret défense les
archives et de les rendre au burkina
faso voyez tout ça ça participe à ce que
j'appelle cette réconciliation nationale
cette vérité par l'histoire et pas
forcément par la justice une mauvaise
justice ici je vous le dis si blaise
compaore revient dans son pays ça sera
un sujet d'union et quand vous aviez
raté mais la france pourrait de
réconciliation être impliqué mais en
tout cas la france doit donner les
archives et l on était prêts elles ont
été promises par le président macron
luna gore keumayou
non je crois qu'on ne peut pas balayer
d'un revers de main la responsabilité de
la france ou d'autres pays comme par
exemple est rien parce que n'oublions
pas que pendant ces périodes là il ya eu
également une guerre au liberia et que
entre candidats et charles taylor choses
qui se sont bel qui a la côte d'ivoire
la côte d'ivoire était le relais de la
france dans cette zone un moment on
avait pensé au togo en expert en
estimant que la françafrique avait
plusieurs piliers en afrique de l'ouest
au togo je faisais partie mais je crois
que la vérité historique c'est que la
françafrique de cette paix vieux plats
et des tellement fort que céder les
chiens étapes et les politiciens qui en
imposait aux entreprises aujourd'hui le
rapport est inversé ce sont les
entreprises à la rigueur qui en impose
aujourd'hui et on pouvait voir où est
née aux états africains donc en cela je
crois qu'il faudra probablement attendre
que des ars mais on a déjà des débuts
d'éléments qui nous font comprendre au
delà des burkinabè qui ont été jugés au
delà de prince johnson qui s'est mis à
table de charles taylor qui est très
probablement impliquées et de la cotivo
avoir du pdj en libye il ya beaucoup de
responsables du pays à une convergence
complot qu'ils ont faits qui ont rendu
ce crime là possible donc tout ce que
nous espérons c'est que le principal
accusé en l'occurrence le président
blaise compaore viendra nous dire sa
part de vérité est fière de nous ôter
tous les doutes qui persistent malgré ce
procès je compte y est de qualifier
d'historique maître guy hervé kam donc
ça veut dire qu'on n'est pas du tout à
la fin de l'histoire
oui on n'est pas à la fin de l'histoire
je pense que tous ceux qui ont intervenu
sont d'accord que
on peut douter que blaise compaoré est
comme ça dans un contexte de
1997 décidé sans s'assurer au moins du
soutien de certaines puissances qu'il
pouvait pas seulement faire un coup
d'état mais tuer le capitaine thomas
sankara il ya des éléments il y a des
indices mais le problème en droit pénal
c'est que oui il faudrait il faut des
faits et je crains que en fait c'est
fait la même avec le déclassement des
archives ne soit pas suffisamment
établis pourquoi j'ai dit ça parce que
je doute que les conversations dans
lesquels où les gens décident écoute ce
monsieur il faut en finir avec lui
qu'ils en prennent note et qu' ils les
envoient tel quel donc c'est clair même
si des gens c'est le sait le sont 10 ben
on aura pas de trace par contre pour ce
qui concerne le cas particulier de la
côte d'ivoire les services secrets du
burkina faso et s'est ressenti dans le
procès ont quand même démontré que le
président houphouët boigny n'avait pas
seulement l'intention et qu'il est passé
donc à lattes avec un n officier puis
voilà il l'aurait dit à cet officier la
écoutes laissent tomber nous avons eu
quelqu'un d'autre pour faire le travail
c'est blaise compaore et ça ce sont des
notes qui existe qui ont été et débattus
dont kalou jobs qui permettent de
montrer que voilà donc la côte d'ivoire
est dans
ce sens que vous dit
absolument en tout cas aux régates du
dossier qui a passé à l'audience m bien
sûr vous voyez que depuis qu'on ne parle
plus du procès on parle d'autre chose
qui est beaucoup l'ancien étudiant
sous scellés à l'audience mais on essaie
de faire passer la vérité au dessus
niveau la responsabilité des étals pour
le burkina la côte d'ivoire peut être la
france ils
étaient des anges que des archives qui
existe qui n'ont pas été versée aux
débats en tout cas le débat reste ouvert
et moi je fais confiance je fais
confiance dans les nouveaux gouvernants
ici ce sont des archives versée aux
débats oui mais pas celle de la france
celle de la cause qui doit être celle de
la france on n'a pas eu encore à sa
suite les archives on n'a fait que se
sont dit que vous aussi si la m guy
hervé kam
à l'isi oui il ya une grande partie des
archives qui ont été versés au dossier
oui mais pas tout et pas depuis les a
choisis déclassifiés par le président
macro
oui oui depuis que le président m'a kron
a dit à ouagadougou en 2017 qu'il allait
déclassifiés ça a été déclassifié et les
archives sont venus donc en deux en deux
volets des archives importantes qui ont
permis n'est ce pas justement de voir
qu'ils pourraient avoir une implication
mais je pense que le juge n'a pas voulu
donc traîner avec le dossier pour
attendre tout cela mais il y a un
important lot d'archivés de de milliers
de pages qui aurait été donc des percées
dans donc l'histoire l'histoire n'est
pas finie
je dit cui elles ont été versées au
dossier personne ne les a eus et
personne ne les a véritablement
exploiter ses arches il y un énorme
travail des milliers de pages il faut
rechercher tous et moi je fais confiance
dans les nouveaux gouvernants du burkina
pour passer au dessus de ce procès et
pour tendre la main à l'histoire à
l'histoire dans sa continuité depuis
sankara mais en passant aussi par le
président campaoré jusqu'à ce qu'
aujourd'hui gouverne le pays le mcr
keumayou vous concluez peut-être
oui mais
on fait confiance à la justice et au
pardon on ne dit pas que cela mais qui
peuvent oublier ce qui s'est passé n'est
pas une invitation parce qu'encore une
fois je rappelle que le président au
passage il avait été chassé de son pays
il s'est retrouvé justement en côte
d'ivoire il lui était interdit de venir
il avait été condamné par contumace
il a fait des pieds et des mains pour
revenir et a exigé d'avoir un procès
pour que toute la vérité soit sue sur la
période pendant laquelle du labour année
son pays je pense plus à honorer le
président blaise compaoré se produire à
peu près comme la faiblesse bokassa à
l'époque affaire à suivre donc merci
beaucoup louis magloire kemayou merci à
vous m guy hervé kam vous étiez avec don
direct de ouagadougou merci également à
dieudonné azulgrana en direct également
de ouagadougou merci beaucoup pierre
olivier sur m pierre-olivier sûr d'avoir
été avec nous le merci à vous tous de
nous avoir suivis et reste avec nous sur
france 24
[Musique]